[Music]
hey everybody it's gary uh we want to
make some more tangible content of like
how to
uh i am not the most uh how-to person
even when i do my own stuff uh but you
know obviously there's so many people uh
that i'm working with on my team and tan
and elliott working on tick tock are
gonna
walk through now some how-to for me my
added value to the how-to
which i think is a commodity but
important thus we're making this video
is understanding the macro which is
you're going to see some how to but
think about the culture that's happening
in the platform think about
what's consumed listen listen to see
what's happening then you'll come up
with ideas listen
then ideas and then the tan and elliot
we'll talk about here so
here's a little how-to in tik tok
what's up guys my name is ellie and i'm
going to give you some hacks on how to
get started with tick tock so let's do
it
one of the biggest things of creating
tick tocks for gary is finding trends
but not conforming to them so we really
like to do is find
really popular tik-tok trends that are
on the come-up before they're
ultra-popular
and find a way that gary's message can
fit into that in a cool way without
completely conforming to the trend in
its entirety my biggest tip is
something's trending don't do exactly
that
take the trend and interpret it into
your world right if i'm selling baseball
cards right now and there's some sort of
challenge
i'm incorporating the cards or the wine
or the marketing or the thing so
taking control of tick-tock instead of
it taking control of you if you're you
know a lemonade stand seller or you sell
ice cream or
you're a lawyer too many think they're
forced into having to figure out how to
dance
instead of understanding that dance
trend needs to be formed
into what you do as a dentist so a big
first step in how i create videos is i
like to go find creators that i like
and see how they structure their videos
so i'll kind of pull one up i'll jot
down some notes on how they're starting
it how they're ending it
how their story is flowing maybe how
they utilize text how they're utilizing
audio
i would just like to go and break down
what i think is working and test stuff
for myself
so i'm gonna kind of walk you through
the process of making a tick tock video
and kind of how to structure it
how to add your text and how to use your
audio the whole nine yards let's do it
so first up is utilizing text so text
seems pretty simple in tiktok
but it takes a little bit of time to get
used to on how you like adjust the
timing
so usually what i'll do is i'll type my
text out so let's say like top five
hats i don't know we're gonna go ahead
and put that in a color block
out of color i usually typically do
white for the starter and then here's
kind of a little bit of a confusing part
you tap the text
go to set duration what i usually like
to do is have it start like a few frames
after the beginning so like it
really emphasizes and pops out for the
person watching the video so usually i
just go right here
drag the start to a little bit after i
start talking
and then drag the end to wherever i want
it to disappear next up we'll go over
the audio settings so usually with audio
i like to go through my 4u page
check out some really popular creators
see what audios that they're using and
trends that we're using
i'll add that to my favorites list and
when you add that to your favorite list
it's super easy just go right back in
go to search go to your favorites and
here i have all of my saved sounds that
i have
um that are trending right now and
essentially all you have to do is
press play press the little check mark
and boom you can go in here and adjust
your volume of the added sound
adjust the volume of your actual voice
and you can even actually go over here
to the little
trim icon and adjust where what part of
the audio that you want to use
it's really helpful and last thing i
want to show you guys is the effect so
the effects is a really great way to
play on the tik-tok trends and really
just emphasize what you're talking about
so
a lot of times people use the green
screen effects all you have to do is
press the
create button down at the bottom and go
over to the effect library so there's
tons of trending effects you can use
you'll probably see a lot of them in
your for you page but i typically love
to stick with the green screen one
they perform pretty well you can really
emphasize what you're talking about so
i'll click on the green screen
boom tap away um you can actually go
right here and swipe through
all the pictures you want to use so
let's say for example i want to use this
here's a picture of me
and you're going to start recording talk
about what you want to super cool
hey it's tan i'm going to go over
repurposing content for tick tock
and also how team garyvee edits on
premiere the first thing i look at
is understanding what people are talking
about i live and die on the discover
page and the for you page
when i click on the discover page i'm
looking at current trends
more importantly i'm actually watching
all the videos to see what kind of
trends they are
and how gary's content can fit into that
conversation one of the most important
part is looking for how recent the
videos are posted on that trend
in this case we're going to look at the
how to trend from there
actually hop on to
search.garyvaynerchuk.com or
youtube.comgaryvee to search for
specific videos
i'm looking for content uh for example
how to find sports cards or how to
sell sports cards online when i'm
watching these long-form videos
i'm looking for some six second moments
where i really physically want to be in
that room
and from there i'll cut it next i'll
open up premiere i'll make sure that
it's 1080 by 1920.
i'll use the tick tac creative guide so
that way all my text emojis
and gifs are inside the frame one tip of
the trick is i use
photoshop files to create the text so
that way it looks native and the cool
thing about
photoshop and premiere is you can drag
the photoshop file into premiere and it
works
a couple of tips and tricks i really
focus on the first three seconds am i
telling the audience
why they should watch it or what's
useful or entertaining about this
video i'll make sure that i title it in
a way where people understand what is
exactly going on
p.s before you get out of here
leaving comments at scale not spam like
follow me but like
literally consuming 150 posts
and then leaving a comment with your two
cents on it is a very big deal on tick
tock
so that's the quick start guide for tick
tock i hope you guys learned something
if you enjoyed that and you got value
from it and it's something you think i
should double down on
please leave a comment and let me know
what you got out of it and do you want
to see more content
like this from our universe hope
everybody's super well
hey everybody on youtube first of all
thank you so much so humbled for your
time if you got some value out of that
there's a plenty for where that came
from feel free to
check it out